All right. Hello. It is the 5th of June 2019 and this is our zoom call for today. We're going to touch on some questions that came in.
Remember if you're new to our clinic, it's very difficult. You're not going to get answers to emails. If you email us questions, if you email us questions there for the zoom call.
If you're having emergency, make sure you call the clinic.
We just, I literally get over 200 emails a day. So please on the email question that you want for the zoom call put in the little part of the email where it says topic or whatever it is subject. That's what it is.
Put zoom questions. So I make sure I catch it when I search for it to get ready for a zoom call.
We had questions about herk cyber reactions. What a herk cyber reaction is typically describing somebody going through biotoxin illness, like they're killing off mold or they're killing off live or cold infections.
But really a herk cyber reaction is when you react to endotoxins. So endotoxins are when you talk about bacteria, if I kill live bacteria in my body, it is the particles of the bacteria that are circulating the blood.
Let's say you blew them up with your immune system. Well, your body doesn't reabsorb those and reutilize those like it does when it kills your own cells.
When it kills bacteria, things that particles from that bacteria are called endotoxins.
Endotoxins can be reactive to your immune system in themselves. Graham negative bacteria like Lyme disease also have like a polysaccharides in the cell membranes and they can react to your immune system that you can feel sick afterwards.
Also, when you're killing cancer cells, you could have herk cyber reactions because if you kill through apoptosis, apoptosis is a recycling of cell matter.
So normal program cell death, aka apoptosis, you don't ever get a herk cyber reaction, you don't liberate any endotoxins because it's recycling that matter.
But when you kill through lysis, like doing chemotherapy, you will get herk cyber type reactions because you kill through a different pathway.
Lysis is the cell basically exploding because of a poison. So it's going through a totally different death cycle because of toxin.
That's what chemotherapy is and that lysis will break apart cell matter and you will get endotoxins there and you can get reactions in immune reactions to those endotoxins as well.
So cancer patients can get herk cyber reactions as well. So those are typically called herk's reactions.
And that's what can happen when you do chemotherapy, that's what can happen when you're killing Lyme disease, herk cyber reactions are not pleasant and the problem is is that you can't completely control that everybody reacts differently, just like somebody going through chemotherapy.
They just quote unquote sail through never have any side effects and another person has horrible side effects even after the first chemotherapy same thing with Lyme, it's impossible to know how someone is going to react to everything.
That's why you have to go really, really slow. So how do you deal with herk cyber reactions? Well, there's no sure way, but the biggest thing is is we have to help the detox pathways.
Here's some of the symptoms that a person would get herk's seen and they can be varied anything that's going to stimulate the immune system can cause a million different symptoms.
So this is a list from Laura sit in a product that we use for Lyme patients sometimes, but it can be much more explosive than this.
But the biggest thing with dealing with this, you have to get endotoxins out of your body. So you have to open up detox pathways. If we have a senior your the health of your detox pathways via your genes yet the genetic pathways, the pound one pathways, the NAT one at 82 pathways.
And that's what you see with people that either have Lyme disease and have a lot of herks type reactions with Lyme disease or people that don't tolerate chemotherapy well.
And that's really the difference that we see with a person who cruise right through chemotherapy with no real herks reactions.
And a person who did not do well with chemotherapy at all, it had to do with the health of their detox pathways genetically.
If a person has a lot of NAT defects, a lot of defects in their set of chrome P450 pathway, and especially their pound one pathway, they don't get rid of endotoxins very well. They don't get rid of chemicals very well.
And therefore they're going to have more reactions to these endotoxins.
So you have to support those pathways supporting the liver, colon, kidneys, skin and lungs that are those are your detox pathways. So we talk about genetics.
We're talking about the liver pathways, but how else can we support the colon, kidneys, skin and lungs.
Well, coffee enemas can help with the liver, can help with the colon. So doing coffee enemas can help dump stuff from the liver and help move things through the colon.
Foot bath detoxes bypass all those main five main areas of detoxification, except they're using your skin that way, just like sona, you're helping push things through your skin, sweating things out that can be an excellent way to help with herks reactions can help with even if you're not all these things have to do with whether you're able to herks reaction, these all have to do with improving detoxification.
From everything. So you're supporting the skin detoxification pathways through sweating, you're supporting it through foot bath detoxing breathing techniques getting outside doing yoga type breathing can be really good because you're getting chemicals out your lungs.
I've said this before the fastest way to poison somebody is to inject them with a poison. The second fastest way to poison somebody is to breathe it in.
Therefore, the fastest way to unpoison someone if that is such a term is through breathing your lungs exchange chemicals those alveolar spaces in your lungs exchange chemicals and you can breathe out toxins as much as you can breathe them in.
So getting out in the fresh air breathing, walking, getting some air, getting that will help that exchange and help that exchange through the blood and get out toxins that are circulating in your blood.
Epsom salt bath can be extremely helpful using binders like bentonite clay, zeolite type products, they can be helpful because they'll bind things in your colon because
there is a percentage of things that once your liver does its job and dumps things into the colon if you don't have a good fast colon intestinal transit time and it's you got your food stay in your colon a little bit longer you will reabsorb those things so using binders all binders do is help grab on the things and keep them in your colon so you could deposit them in the toilet.
That's what binders are doing so that's another thing that could help with dealing with herc cyber reactions.
So keep up that whether you think I'm having a herc cyber reaction these are all good detox things so the more things you can do to to help take pressure off your liver to help get things out of your body the better off you're going to be.
So think of it that way whether you feel like you're having a detox reaction or not.
The other questions that came in this week were again talking about pain we address this on a zoom call a few weeks back but I think it needs to be addressed again because more questions came through with this.
Obviously the paid medications that are out there work better than any natural thing that you can have.
You could take curcum in and things like that that I'm going to recommend here as well and of course it didn't made a lids and bromelade and things like that nothing is going to work as quick as this.
The problem with taking medications for paid is guess what they go back and they cause these things because you have to detoxify this stuff.
This chemical once it might block block the Cox to pathway and block the paid pathway that has to be detoxified out of the body and it's got to go through these pathways again and so this paid medication is a major cause of blocked pathways.
So and you know it's a major cause of injury to the liver it's a major cause of you know back up and clogging the liver and that's what is another piece you talk about why do people have these first reactions why do they get these things.
Well I mentioned because of those those detox those defects on those genes on the detox pathways but another major reason maybe the most common thing is abuse of their liver over the years and you can think well i've never taken medication many prescription medication over the counter medication over the years damages your liver.
Even if you've never taken medication i'm a person that my parents never brought me to the doctor never took any drugs when I was a kid we went to the car proctor we did things naturally when I was a kid so I feel like my liver is pretty clean never really drake never did drugs never did anything like that but you're so exposed to everything in this environment.
100 times more than our great grandparents were.
So there's so many assaults goes way beyond this on our liver that caused my liver to be sluggish and then slows down my whole pathways makes be a very slow detoxifier and and I end up having problems.
So here's some natural helps to curcumin these are detox pathway helps with these are pain helps and these are natural anti-inflammatories white willow bark corset and bus wellia batalins we talked about batalins and that is an enzyme from beats that is very good for inflammation.
Bromalade rosemary CBD THC are probably our most powerful and fast acting paid relievers that we have from a natural perspective and ginger we use the product clear inflamed that has a lot of these different things in but the CBD and the THC are probably our most fast acted.
Pied relievers that we have an our disposal from a natural perspective so this is the best CBD that I think is on the market right now this is a really strong CBD this is a paste it comes in a tube that's a paste I've used this before with a lot of success I've also used this with a lot of success too so both of these are really good products this also has this one has an immune booster in a tube.
Okay I got to unmute everybody got about 10 more minutes for questions so you could everybody is unmuted unless you muted yourself so feel free to jump in and ask questions is the evolve taken orally or on the pain area.
So both of these are oral products there is another sad CBD sad that we have that's a topical sad and we get all we have so many people order that aren't even our patients it's just a really, really popular product it's called case have it's tested really well for a lot of topical cancers as well.
I wasn't you know with with any of the CBD saves that are out there I'm a little cautious because I don't know the concentration of CBD that's in it we're getting really good results with that as well a lot of people are using it for our rightest type paid to it does it's more of a clear staff so it doesn't leave any stating like those have been with us a long time have maybe used our curcumin.
It's a very extreme that has worked really well for paid and really well for topical cancers that are not melanoma like basal cell cancers the curcumin cream the negative that is it's kind of yellow it's very strong yellow orange color and it states your clothes and your bed pillow cases and things like that the case have a topical sad these two are oral.
This is a water soluble oral the evolved entourage the water soluble oral this is a paste that you scored out about two three size grades of right size onto your finger and take it it tastes a little ash and does not taste anything like the Rick Simpson oil.
And it doesn't have the same negative effects as far as symptom wise is Rick Simpson oil it does have some CBD in it or some THC it but it's fairly small amount so not anything that you'd really notice and then not pictured here is the THC because we can't sell the THC.
The THC for chronic paid either taken smoked in a pipe or in a in a marijuana cigarette will help with paid and or cooked in like a food or something like that or heated and rendered and used in like a coconut oil.
Application or something like that is how THC is used as far as for paid goes.
It can't be either so it depends on what's going on you can be either one so her actions can range from.
You know your head feeling like it's going to explode to your joints reacting to it can be literally anything.
I've got a question off topic if you'll take that of course.
On the rife machine frequencies notice sometimes on the true rife emails I get they say there's an update to the frequencies do we need to do that Dr. Connor you do if you want to use that updated program.
So if you update the frequencies as it says on the true rife emails it will not change the program that I created you for you.
So you just need to be connected you need to have your rife computer connected to Wi-Fi and then super simple so if your rife computer is connected to the Wi-Fi.
Open up a rife program in the program itself in the upper right hand corner I believe it says update frequencies.
Click on that and it'll say please wait while we're updating your frequencies takes about three or four minutes.
It's all updated.
Just on that particular program that you have open no it'll update all your programs.
Oh it'll update all the programs.
Yeah so it updates everything so if Mike a true rife you know came up with another program or if you know and it's people like me that send them programs here here's another program for the you know when I first started with them there was about 500 programs that we had.
And now there's over 2000 programs that we have in there so if there's updated frequencies for a new flu typically in with her will have an updated flu program and I just saw email and he had something else updated I can't remember what it was of course the other.
Yeah it was the cancer one of the cancer.
Oh yeah I think one of it was a foot bath or I think I can't remember.
Yeah so it's it could you know if you're only running the programs that we we created for you then it doesn't make any difference whether you update anything.
But if you are if you're running some of the other programs which you know we recommend you do then sure to update your frequencies on every three months or so it was a good idea.
If you come back again do you update.
If you bring the your computer with you.
Yes sir.
We will and if your question is will we update your program it totally depends on how you're doing.
We have patients that let's say are not doing well they're going to the wrong direction and they'll come back for a rescan to recheck and we'll tweak something so we'll change their program around.
Typically if a person's like going in the right direction then we do not change their program.
Okay thank you very much.
Absolutely.
Dr. Conner.
Uh huh.
This is Donna.
And I have two questions.
One is somebody told me the other day that tomatoes and other night shapes could be damaging the colon and therefore you know when I use some spectrum to try to heal then it's counteractive.
Does that make sense to you?
Yeah it partly depends on if you have any sensitivity to night chains.
So night chains can't be inflammatory.
Um and but but remember, take a step back just because something is inflammatory does not mean it's bad.
Remember what I've said over and over again you need a balance of inflammation and anti inflammation you need a balance of oxidation and anti oxidation.
All you had is anti inflammatory and antioxidants.
That would not be a good thing you wouldn't kill bacteria you wouldn't kill cancer cells you wouldn't you know you need to be in that balance.
Because you know we tend to talk about oh we need to decrease inflammation.
Well you need sources you need that those little spikes of inflammation at different times to so food can give you those.
Um so it's not something to shy away from but that's being said some people have sensitivities to.
Different categories of foods night chains is one lectins is that other gluten is another.
Um you know things like that so those different categories need to be addressed if a person notices you know you can do it either through an elimination diet know that boy I tend to feel worse when I eat.
When I eat night chains I tend to feel worse when I have vasoactive amines so you cut those out of your diet and it doesn't mean that you have to stay away from them forever you might want to cycle them back in.
So remember what we've talked about to that you know part of my belief at least is that God created us to eat in season really and we live in a world today that we could get apples.
So 365 days a year and so we tend to be habitual people at habitual eaters.
And I've told the story of this little girl I had my first patient 35 years ago where she couldn't sleep more than an hour and a half at a time she was four years old.
The mother looked like she got run over by a cement truck. She was just going to help me.
I tested her with kinesiology she came up sensitive to vasoactive amines which is another category of food tomatoes really high and vasoactive amines.
They were a strong Italian family and the mother said oh my gosh we eat spaghetti sauce, breakfast, lunch and dinner.
We went off of that and within just a couple weeks she was sleeping through the night and her whole life changed.
She was able to go back on it but within reason and cycle it so that's the way it is with many foods.
Now if we do an antibody test on you like a Cyrex antibody test you show up very high in antibodies and certain foods you have to go off of those.
And it takes a period of time for your body to get rid of those antibodies and then you can tend to go back on those foods in moderation and not have issues.
The only real exception of that is gluten because there's been so many studies about gluten that the gluten antibodies can last for years and years and years.
But other antibodies like tapioca starch or cinnamon and any other food you can think of, they tend to believe that the half life is a matter of days with those.
So beat off of it for about three months usually will dissipate those antibodies that you will have reactions to those again.
Well, I don't usually have any kind of reactions to them but she had mentioned it to me.
The second question I have is I've been reading a book called Magnetium Miracles by Carol and Dean. Are you familiar with her?
Yes, I am.
And what do you think about her?
Well, I think she's good. I think you just you only have to the only thing I tell you to be cautious about is that I do think that magnesium is an important element and it's an important substance because if you look at your genetic pathways, magnesium is necessary, it's a necessary co factor for about half of them, which we're talking thousands of pathways.
So magnesium is an important nutrient.
Does that mean we all need to be supplementing with magnesium? I don't think so.
Does it mean that it would be good to supplement with magnesium at times? Yes.
And go back to a video that had Dr. Halter and do she was a medical doctor that worked with me for multiple different times over the years.
She did a really nice presentation on cycling your supplements and the benefits of cycling different supplements like your minerals like maybe I won't take magnesium every single day, but maybe I'll take it a few times a week.
And or maybe I'll take it for five days and it won't take it for a week and it'll take it for five more days.
That is a good idea because that's kind of the way we were created to eat.
You know, we eat what's available and then we don't have it for a while and we eat again.
And that kind of goes with the whole thought of fasting as well. There's times that we eat and we have a lot of food and there's times that we don't have food and that's when a topogy happens that our body can clean out of some different things.
But obviously, you know, with the amount of magnesium products that we have in our store, that's a big thing for me. I take magnesium, but again, I do not take it every day. I take it probably three to four times a week.
I use, I switch around the products to, I use magnesium, but I use the, the, Magdezium, that's in the powder form and put it in my shake sometimes because I want that call me defect on the brain as well.
Yeah. Okay. Very good. I appreciate your time and answer my questions. Oh, you're back. Good time
for maybe one more question. Well, all right. Well, thank you guys for being on. This was recorded
and this will be up on the Facebook page for those who weren't on it and couldn't listen.
And again, you have questions. Make sure you email them in to me and just put in the
of the subject bar.